An experiment to describe your surroundings
with Seeing AI.
Seeing AI is an ongoing research project.
And in the app, we have included some of our
more experimental features, that you have
to turn those on in the settings.
One of these is the ability to describe a
general scene.
When you take a photo, the algorithm detects
the objects that it can see.
And tries to find a relationship between them
and describe this in a natural sentence.
It’s still learning, kind of like a kid
learns to speak.
So, as it learns more things In the world
around it, the descriptions will get better
over time.
Here’s an example photo I took earlier.
> Processing.
> Probably a man sitting on a couch using
a laptop.
> Take picture
> Processing.
> A bus that is parked on the side of a road.
> Take picture
> Processing.
> Probably a box filled with different types
of food on the table.
This is just a glimpse at the possibilities
of artificial intelligence.
And I can’t wait to see where it goes in
the future.
Microsoft logo appears.